oh wow this one this one's really fun
it takes her whole body to need together
we have 96 slices of cheese on the
scroll cheese we're gonna play with fire
[Music]
welcome back to making a big this is the
show where I make giant food from my
friends and special guests I've always
wanted to make a giant grilled cheese no
one's asked me to do it but I love
cheese poles and I've been really
inspired by this channel called healthy
junk food they've mastered the art of
making these crazy giant foods I thought
it'd be fun to invite them in to see if
they maybe judge one of my creation so
let's go meet them how are you thanks
for coming in just for the people who
might not know who you guys are what do
you guys do my name is Julia and this is
JP we're JP and Julia and we started
healthy junk food back in 2013 to try to
actually be healthier we started just
doing copycat recipes of like Big Macs
and Crunchwrap Supremes making a
healthier and then we're like hey let's
make it bigger I like the way you think
you guys have made several amazing giant
grilled cheese videos one of the
trickiest things about making a giant
gold cheese is you got to get that
ultimate cheese pull so when I get to
that point I might ask you guys to come
you know come and help me out because
I've never done it before and I really
think your expertise would help me make
that cheese kle really awesome I'm good
with that
as long as you have to me a soup I need
to be dipping it in there so you guys
feel free to hang out and chill out I'm
gonna go work in the kitchen and go from
there see you guys here for ya thanks
for ya room before you go 18 for Alvin
okay we're gonna make giant grilled
cheese and the first step in giant
grilled cheese is giant bread so we're
gonna take nine cups of warm water this
will help make sure that the yeast is
nice and activated not too hot it also
it'll kill it
oil salt sugar woof and yeast and just
gonna mix this together until all of the
sugar and the salt and the yeast is kind
of like dissolved in the water these
tool kind of incorporate and start
growing all right that's looking pretty
good
next step is ten cups of flour a lot of
flour but we're gonna do this in batches
- this is only half of it trying to make
sure there's no huge lumps welcome to
ASMR with Alvin this is about half of
the flour and we're gonna add the second
half this is a total of around like 40
cups will help her this is gonna Nate
make enough bread for the whole entire
dough
okay so it's coming together we're gonna
turn it out onto the table finish
kneading whoo boy bench flour
whoo LeBron James LeBron James LeBron
James there we go oh that was a bad idea
it's gonna start needing this guy oh
we're gonna need a lot of flour this
looks like a job of the hunt whoo okay
this is the dough we'll call him my
bread baby and this is enough dough for
both slices of bread the grilled cheese
so we're actually gonna divide him in
half mmm that's cool all right awesome
so we have two dough balls each one will
make one slice of bread for the grilled
cheese you will need to prove for 30
minutes so I'm gonna cover them and wait
for them to grow up in size we have a
lot of time while the bread proofs so
we're gonna make a tomato soup because
you can't have a giant gold cheese
without a lot of tomato soup we're gonna
go on with a good amount of motor oil as
Gordon Ramsay likes to say we're gonna
throw in some vegetables so we have
garlic have celery and we've onions oh
it smells great so we're gonna add some
salt to tastes pepper and tomato paste
and this has to be cooked out a bit can
I spread this around fry it up a bit
very tomatoey getting a tomato steam
face bath well let's cook down a bit
caramelizing real nice so now I think
it's ready to put in the liquid
ingredients or going with the crushed
tomatoes we have eight 28 ounce cans of
tomatoes 224 ounces of tomatoes total
then 6 quarts of vegetable broth
whoo-hoo and also
some nice fresh basil I love this stuff
always sniff your basil before you
hidden your food guys it doesn't change
anything about the food but it makes you
feel better we're gonna bring this to a
boil and I'll see you guys in a bit it's
been 30 minutes this is looking amazing
so at this point we have a lot of
tomatoes in here that's a lot of acidity
see we want to add some baking soda it's
basic like a couple of my friends and
it's gonna help balance and counteract
that acidity from the tomatoes okay so
it's been simmering for a while it's
kind of mellowed out a bit
now we're gonna play with it this is
probably one of my favorite weapons of
mass destruction in the kitchen it is a
immersion blender whoo we're gonna be
blending and puree all those vegetables
we added in earlier some of the crushed
Tomatoes some of the basil this is so
good pretty good
obviously you gotta add some heavy cream
this is not diet food but it's freaking
amazing so we're gonna go for it all
those beautiful streaks just start
coming to the surface oh that's good
well we made three gallons of creamy
tomato soup to go along with the grilled
cheese we're gonna take this to the back
and continue making our giant grilled
cheese okay so our dough has been
proofing for roughly an hour these will
be the size of each bread slice because
it's the largest pan that we can fit in
a tasty oven come on okay it's ringing
with our fingertips spread these out to
the corners of the tray in this process
were also knock down a little bit of the
air that had come from the bacteria
farts during the proofing section all
righty
that's one this off here number two come
on whoa that's awesome
I'll never get tired of that whoo oh wow
this one's this one's really fun trying
to get a lot of the air out of this cool
well this one looks great
these two are going to proof for another
30 minutes do their final rise before we
get them into the
these have been proofing for about 30
minutes they got a little bigger in size
it's gotten a lot smoother and shinier
and basically these are ready for the
oven we're gonna bake two giant slices
of bread
[Music]
[Music]
we have some pretty awesome bread slices
right now one thing I think that's
important about grilled cheese is that
it is made with slices of bread not the
ends of the bread so that means both
sides do not have a crust on the heart I
get in here you start off slow
[Music]
whoa this is so cool since both sides of
these need to be trimmed I have an idea
that I think will make it look like it
is trim so we're gonna go with a
microplane it sort of grade off the
crust of the bread to make some bread
crumbs oh it's working
oh yeah strategy worked out nicely cuz I
think if I went in with a knife on both
sides
I'm not amazing at knife skills I might
have just destroyed the bread and made
it like not usable at all but it's
looking pretty good okay so I've been
chisel away at this thing for quite a
while so yeah this is looking pretty
good this is our bottom slice kind of
has a little well into it like a little
bread well with little bread walls so
that the cheese will not escape we have
four beautiful and amazing cheese's we
have mozzarella cheddar American and
Hardy so we'll start with cheddar and
then we'll go with mozzarella so
American and some Havarti look at that
for fit perfectly want to build a grid
here four kinds of cheeses
we have 24 rows of cheese each row has
four cheeses in it so we have 996 slices
of cheese on the scroll cheese
okay so we're gonna brush this with
butter a lot of melted butter a lot of
bread so you need a lot of butter we're
gonna put like two sticks of butter on
this guy it's a lot but hey it's gonna
be great
and if you're eating grilled cheese I
don't think you're worried too much
about that content anyways okay so this
is the really really fun part we got to
play with fire this is a cool tool that
spreads out the flame over a larger area
because it's kind of hard to get this
bread into a pan that's big enough to
toast so we're gonna use fire instead
and I like playing with it so
[Music]
okay so I've been here for about like 30
minutes just searing the spilled cheese
it smells great the butter the bread
it's browning we're making brown butter
basically this looks really good we're
getting a really nice crust and we're
gonna actually take this guy this is a
beautiful display of cheese 96 slices
and we're going to put it in the oven so
I'll see you guys in a bit guys look at
this
looks so awesome it's like a
checkerboard full of cheese I'm super
excited that it kept its shape okay it's
going together real nicely we're gonna
put it back in the oven or like 20
minutes or so so off we go and oh this
is a heavy grilled cheese oh my god all
right this is the final baked grilled
cheese it's been in the oven for a total
of 45 minutes the top and the bottom are
thoroughly heated it's crispy it's
crackly if you can hear we have these
giant pizza peels that were gonna try to
use to get this onto the board that's
one
here we go
[Music]
nice I'm about to cut it but the thing
is this is a pretty tricky part and I
don't want to mess it up so I'm gonna
call in the experts
JP Julia you want to come in and help me
out I'm here to help you all they make
you how's it going
good that's bigger than ours oh I
thought yours is like super huge no I'm
proud okay there we go oh my goodness
we're in come on Alvin come on Alvin you
have beautiful hands thank you put
concealer on them sometimes one nice
long stroke through to make sure we're
even
so the strategy I think we should try to
get our hands underneath to try to
support as much of it along the seam as
possible yeah like this actually
so maybe Julie if you want to get this
area just like a little cheese baby one
to
[Music]
that was crazy he's me I heard you guys
wanted tomato soup oh my goodness
oh yeah mamacita hurt yourself there I'm
gonna get a Sun interview excuse me oh
no oh you guys do not mess around the
flavor this is flavortown
see you got a little one and you got
enjoy it one okay okay yeah I think you
have a little something on your face
Julie can help me do you want to take
that one home uh-huh all right guys next
time thank you
well fun I got to live out my dream of
making a giant grilled cheese who better
than JP and Juliet to judge if it was
awesome it sounded like they are pretty
impressed with what we were able to make
today that was awesome
and here's the thing if you guys have
any ideas of giant foods that you would
like to see us make on this show leave a
comment tell us what you want to see
send me a message we do read them but
until next time
[Music]